des stocks de sang à un niveau critique
des donneurs moins nombreux à cause de
la crise sanitaire
l'établissement français du sang leur a
d'ailleurs lancé un appel parmi ces
donneurs les hommes homosexuels pendant
très longtemps
de 1983 à 2016 ils ont pourtant été
interdit de donner leur sang elle fait
peur comme un cancer on n'en finit plus
de parler du sida depuis plusieurs mois
les médias parlent abondamment d'une
maladie mystérieuse le sida début des
années 80 les années sida une communauté
particulièrement touchée celle des
homosexuels pour éviter de propager le
virus
un arrêté signé en 1983 parmi les
mesures prises
l'interdiction aux homosexuels de donner
leur sang à l'individu lambda se
présenta centre qui récupère le sens on
lui fait remplir un questionnaire qui
est anonyme et il ya une question qui
demande indirectement si on est
homosexuel
durant toute cette période les
témoignages des homosexuels sur le don
du sang sont absents des télés leurs
paroles ne se fait entendre qu'à la fin
des années 90 a refusé mon sens parce
que j'étais homosexuel et
une malgré le g certifie est absolument
que je ne vais pas de rapports
extraconjugaux
en 2002 les lesbiennes sont autorisés à
donner leur sang
mais les hommes eux sont toujours
écartés moi je n'ai aucune maladie pas
de sida pas d'hépatite e rien du tout je
vois pas pourquoi je peux pas donner de
sens qu'à qu'a fait ce qu'il veut de
cette sexualité ça doit pas avoir
recours à frénette addictions les sauver
des vies c'est apple finira par être
entendu
seulement en partie en 2016 un arrêté
met fin à trente trois années
d'interdiction pour les hommes
homosexuels mais à une condition celle
de ne pas avoir eu de rapports sexuels
pendant un an avant le don par cette
petite contrainte d'abstinence en fait
la plupart d'entre nous sont toujours
effectivement exclu lieu dans douze
autres depuis avril 2020 la période
d'abstinence pour les hommes homosexuels
et bisexuels a été réduite passant de un
an à 4 mois
une première étape vers un alignement
des conditions de dons pour les
homosexuels sur celle des hétérosexuels
[Musique]